Wondering how much a revenue-based
funding option could cost your business?
Let’s break it down in a way that’s easy to
understand—and could save you a lot of headaches!
When it comes to revenue-based funding, the cost
is based on a unique rate called a ‘factor rate.’
Think of this as the magic number that
determines how much you’ll pay back.
Factor rates typically range from 1.18 to
1.55—but what does that really mean for you?
Let’s say your business is approved for $30,000.
Depending on your factor rate, your repayment
could range between $35,400 and $46,500.
Yep, that’s $5,400 to $16,500 extra,
all determined by your factor rate.
Now you might be asking:
‘What factor rate will I get?’
Well, that depends on how strong
your business performance is.
The better your numbers, the better your rate!
But wait, there’s more!
Some funding providers might
include an origination fee,
which is like a setup charge ranging
anywhere from 0-5% of the advance amount.
On a $30,000 advance, that’s an
extra $0 to $1,500 right off the top!
Since not all providers include this fee,
it’s crucial to verify with your
provider whether they do or not.
After all, it’s better to know
upfront before agreeing or signing
anything than to find out later—when
it’s too late to change your mind!
Ultimately, here’s the bottom line: revenue-based
funding can be a lifeline for many businesses,
but knowing the real cost is key
to making the right decision.
The better informed you are, the
better you can plan for success.
Got questions?
Drop them in the comments,
and let’s chat about it!